oh hello welcome to our stage just want
to show you bingo there are our
Department recreated these real
apartments that we shot and initially
check this freaking apartment wall out
you know in Seinfeld they were like look
at our client apartments or whatever
it's like nothing like New York this is
like New Yorkers made this apartment
when we shot on location they found
these two doors next to each other and
one was normal and one was like a
sticker collage that would be Alana's
and then when that dirty asshole got
elected and it became all activist
stickers which is sad but funny and
informative
it's Angelique Clark everybody yes I
love these wig heads are so funny
Alana's wigs cracks me up because the
sacraments ain't when I was 12
you better believe I have a metal weed
box so some cool PA found these these
are made out of old plastic bags and
also our PA made these these like plant
holders out of white for success just
like thank-you bags right yeah it's fun
when we have real pictures we took this
out like the season one rap party I
think
Arturo Castro and a be hopeless I'm a
and a B and me and that's real oh my god
maybe I'll take this yeah today's our
last day on set and it's gonna truly go
away forever I've never seen on TV a
more disgusting bathroom I mean
absolutely grotesque yeah it's pretty
gross it's pretty gross
okay so let's try you in my room it's
funny it's like forced processing just
take this off a second just to maybe get
some pictures after in the web series
Abbi made these this cardboard trumpet
for some weird thing we did out of
tampon boxes and then it was recreated
for the show these I had hanging in my
room these boobs from oh it's from a
sketch show I did at UCB to
mature the tits on the wall we framed
them this is Alana's workstation she
is a professional now since you're like
an eco-warrior you know like these are
all made from like milk cartons
you know recycled water bottles and of
course you have like you know like your
condoms and your tampons and your
vampire teeth the credit goes to us but
it's John Cox and Angela Clark and Jess
Petrocelli but it's also like literally
a dozen queer young people of color who
are really the new broad city that are
actually executing this the
clothes organization cracks me up it's
like so organized and this is my real
life of like being visual this is weird
because like this used to be my sweater
but like it's like you know like I felt
like it was like I had to like give it
to you for yourself funny it's so funny
it really like the show ending is like
it's ending for all of us it's not just
me and Abby will be doing the project
since 2009 it's good to keep moving
forward you know with every ending is a
new beginning yeah I can't get it now
for dad hmm
[Music]